tropical storm durian exactly is
barreling toward Puerto Rico and
Islanders now expect a direct hit
forecasters say the storm is gaining
strength before it's likely landfall
there later today authorities say it
could bring landslides life threatening
flooding and power outages - the latest
data says durian is also on track to hit
the Bahamas and Florida later this week
as a possible category 2 hurricane
President Trump has already declared an
emergency in Puerto Rico and our lead
national correspondent David Begg know
is in Ponce a puerto rico which was
ravaged by hurricane Maria just two
years ago David there you are a good
morning in the thick of it again what
are the weather conditions there right
now beautiful you wouldn't know anything
is coming Tony overnight the storm
strengthened slightly now 60 miles per
hour and the the track that the path of
the storm is kind of moved north so the
metro area of San Juan where the
majority of people live they look like
they're gonna get a direct hit listen if
you're sitting at home this morning
saying David don't over blow it you know
talking about a direct hit with a
tropical storm please be mindful of this
you're talking about a tropical storm
heading to a very vulnerable island with
a weak grid that collapsed after
Hurricane Maria and it's still being
rebuilt right now the fear that this
could be disastrous is why the federal
government has sent 500 employees here
in addition to the 3,000 they already
have it's why the local government has
told people gather 10 days of supplies
it's why people who are still reeling
from hurricane Maria are very worried
about durian as tropical storm durian
takes aim at Puerto Rico people here are
still recovering from the devastation of
Hurricane Maria and that was two years
ago so that's why now
they are preparing for the worst the
island is not pretty anymore some people
who don't trust the government's
preparations have decided to leave I'm
so unsecured here
with the power the the food the security
so I'm leaving
most people are staying we went to FEMA
to find out how ready they are what
gives you confidence that you're better
prepared now I think first of all the
amount of supplies we have two years
after Hurricane Maria 30 thousand homes
are still covered with blue tarps at
about 1,000 roads remain impassable
around the island if you look around
just at this warehouse and now we have
five where we used to have one there's
probably ten times the commodities on
the island that we're here pre maria so
we've spent the last two years learning
some lessons and making sure they were
much better prepared yesterday president
Trump claimed that Congress approved
ninety two billion dollars in aid for
Puerto Rico after Maria's devastation
that's not true
Congress has only allocated roughly
forty three billion less than fourteen
billion of that has actually gotten to
the island well learning from what went
wrong the CEO of the islands Power
Company Jose Ortiz made a bold
prediction last night he said if the
entire island were to lose power in a
worst-case scenario he predicts he could
have the lights back on
in two weeks we have to restore as quick
as possible it's not acceptable what
happening the last time that many people
wait for 11 months
to get power back imagine if it was your
family so it's gonna be different that's
a tall prediction for mr. Ortiz we'll
have to see what happens listen after
Hurricane Maria the communications grid
collapsed nobody could talk to anybody
so FEMA's brought in a hundred satellite
phones that they want to give to every
mayor on the island but if you're
watching the CBS Evening News last night
we told you that the phones hadn't been
activated
and we were less than 24 hours from
landfall this morning FEMA says they're
activated and they are gonna hand one
out to every single mayor today
Adriana they don't have much time we're
talking less than 15 hours we should
start feeling the effects of the storm
not much time at all David Beckmann
Puerto Rico thank you